Transcriptor: Luis Fernando Novelo Tellez
Revisor: Emma Gon
Cuando recibí la invitación
para dar una charla TED,
por la cual estoy muy agradecida
y me puse muy contenta,
me puse a pensar
cuál es la idea transformadora
que quería transmitirles
desde mi punto de vista,
desde mi experiencia.
Y me puse a pensar
que estoy preocupada
por cómo manejamos la información,
y por cómo la información
nos maneja a nosotros.
Entonces, les propongo pensar
en que es importante que aprendamos
una nueva forma de pensar.
El 2 de julio pasado
tuve la suerte, la gran suerte,
de poder ver el eclipse total solar
en Chivilcoy,
en la provincia de Buenos Aires.
Fue mi primer eclipse total,
les aseguro que fue una de las
experiencias más impresionantes en mi vida
Fue impresionante ver ese eclipse.
Y creo que lo disfruté aún mas
por el hecho de estar entendiendo
lo que estaba pasando.
Por el hecho de estar conectada
conscientemente con el hecho.
Sabía como funcionaba un eclipse,
que estaba pasando.
Pude ver la corona solar
por primera vez en mi vida.
Fue impresionante
el momento en que del eclipse parcial
pasa a ser un eclipse total,
es un momento que realmente te pone
la piel de gallina y te hace llorar.
Fue realmente impresionante.
Pero pude ver también la sombra
de la Luna sobre la Tierra,
puede escuchar los animales
totalmente alterados
y me puse a pensar
"qué lindo, qué lindo momento".
También hicimos un experimento
muy divertido con nuestra familia
en ese mismo momento
que estaba en Rosario,
en el que proyectábamos la sombra
de un colador de fideo sobre una pared
y veíamos múltiples imágenes del eclipse
pasando por cada uno de
los agujeritos del colador de fideo
¿No es hermoso eso?
Así que nos divertimos,
pero me puse a pensar
cuánto más intensamente
vivimos los momentos,
si no solamente estamos
conectados emocionalmente,
si no, cuando entendemos
lo que está pasando.
Mi mente, mi cerebro y mi corazón
estaban latiendo juntos
porque estaba entendiendo
y porque estaba sintiendo.
Y eso es lo que nos hace
profundamente humanos.
Ese mismo día del eclipse
recibo un WhatsApp,
que seguramente muchos de ustedes
han de haber recibido,
de una amiga que lo mandaba a un grupo
de WhatsApp de unas 20 personas
y era un mensaje reenviado
de una oftalmóloga,
aparentemente muy conocida,
que trabajaba en una clínica
también de mucho prestigio,
en donde ella alertaba
de los grandes problemas para la salud
que podría causar este eclipse.
Que se producirían tormentas solares
y que podían producir
derretimientos de retina
y ceguera total.
También por supuesto,
alertaba que no había que mirarlo,
y eso estaba bien.
Pero también decía que
no podíamos salir de nuestras casas
y que teníamos que desenchufar
todos los aparatos.
Bueno, entonces cuando le pregunté
a mi amiga y le digo:
"¿Vos realmente creés que esto
es cierto, que esto es verdad?"
Me dice: "No, la verdad es que no.
Pero por si acaso lo reenvío".
Evidentemente no había pensado
antes de reenviar el mensaje.
Esto es cuando me preocupé
qué hacemos con la información,
como manejamos nosotros la información
y como la información
nos está manejando a nosotros.
La información,
gran parte de la información
apela a nuestras emociones
para convencernos.
Nos inspiramos, nos asustamos, flasheamos,
nuestro talón de aquiles
son nuestras emociones.
Si no hacemos un esfuerzo consciente,
racional para darle una vuelta
más de tuerca a las cosas,
para tratar de entender
lo que está pasando,
nos vamos a volver y
nos volvemos muy vulnerables.
Es por eso,
que me puse a pensar en la racionalidad
y me acordé de haber leído
lo que dijo Descartes en el siglo XVII
en su discurso del método.
En donde decía,
todo mundo lo sabe,
"yo pienso por lo tanto soy",
o sea, yo pienso y luego existo,
y que se contrapone a la filosofía
donde estamos cayendo actuamente.
Creo yo,
que es más bien se contrapone a eso
y dice algo así como:
"yo creo por lo tanto debe ser cierto",
o más bien, el "Ah che,
mira vos, por si acaso lo reenvío".
Y de esa forma,
esa forma es peligrosa,
porque no es responsable,
porque de esta forma
se generan las noticias falsas,
se generan y se transmiten
las teorías conspirativas,
las teorías alarmistas
y que pueden generar reacciones en
la población que pueden ser peligrosas.
Hace un tiempo leí en los medios locales
que un grupo de personas
anda diciendo
que las estelas de los aviones,
son en realidad vapores químicos
que son muy nocivos para nuestra salud.
Y que alguien nos está, o algunos,
nos están fumigando.
Es realmente, es real esto, es verdad,
¿realmente debemos preocuparnos?
Los gobiernos tienen que dedicar tiempo,
esfuerzo, recursos públicos,
para atacar este problema,
para tomar cartas en el asunto.
Priorizando esto frente a otros problemas
que podemos llegar a tener.
Por otro lado, la semana pasada,
muy recientemente
en mi cuenta de Facebook recibo
el informe final
del panel intergubernamental de
la biodiversidad de las Naciones Unidas.
Es un informe lapidario,
en ese informe alerta sobre la gran
degradación de la naturaleza antropogénica
o sea que la estamos generando
nosotros con nuestra forma de vida,
con nuestro consumismo
y por consecuencia también peligra,
tiene peligro de extinción
están en peligro de extinción
más de 1 millon de especies
de animales y de plantas
y vegetales.
Esto es cierto, también
lo que ellos mismos dicen
y también uno lo lee,
que muchas personas
descreen de esto,
que muchos gobiernos tampoco
toman en cuenta la evidencia científica
que les está diciendo
este panel de las Naciones Unidas
y no toman cartas en el asunto.
Esto si que es grave, porque si no hacemos
algo ahora con lo que estamos pasando,
con el cambio climático,
con la degradación de la naturaleza,
ponemos en riesgo
no solamente al resto de la especies,
si no, a nosotros mismos
y a nuestra supervivencia.
Los gobiernos están gobernando,
toman en cuenta la evidencia
y la información científica,
el conocimiento científico para la toma
de decisiones, para la planificación,
para el dictado de leyes.
Sería fundamental que tomaran mucho
más en cuenta la información científica
y el conocimiento para tomar decisiones.
No es la primera vez
que encontramos una revolución,
un cambio tecnológico tan grande.
Por otro lado,
este cambio tecnológico no ha venido
acompañado con un cambio cultural
y cognitivo de parte nuestra
para tratar de adaptarnos a esto,
para no dejarnos avasallar
y manipular por este cambio.
La tecnología siempre avanza
mucho más rápido que lo que avanzamos
nosotros culturalmente como sociedad,
por eso yo estoy preocupada.
A mediados del siglo pasado,1950,
también hubo un cambio tecnológico
muy importante que nos llevó a cambiar
la forma en que vemos el mundo.
Fue el desarrollo de las armas nucleares,
que a mi particularmente
me preocupa muchísimo,
que aún es una amenaza que pende sobre
nosotros como una espada de Damocles.
Hay más de 15 000 bombas
nucleares amenazándonos,
listas para ser usadas.
Muchas de ellas de un poder de detonación
más de 1000 veces más potente
que la bomba de Hiroshima.
Son números grandes,
por favor piénsenlo
cuando se vayan a casa,
es muy preocupante.
Bueno, a mediados del siglo pasado
frente a este situación,
Albert Einstein y Bertrand Russell junto
con otros 9 científicos muy reconocidos,
la mayoría de los cuales Premios Nobel,
escribieron un manifiesto en el que decía
que sí queremos evitar la destrucción
total por estas armas nucleares,
los países debían necesariamente buscar
soluciones pacíficas para sus conflictos.
Un documento muy pacifista.
Y además, deberían usar
argumentos racionales
para afrontar estos problemas
y buscar confianza mutua.
La palabra confianza es algo
que tenemos que generar.
En este documento ellos decían,
si queremos sobrevivir, debemos aprender
a pensar de una nueva manera.
Decían ellos ya en ese documento y
eso es lo que yo rescaté para esta charla.
Este fue el último acto
público de Albert Einstein,
la firma de este documento,
porque murió unos meses después.
Así que, es como que,
fue una de las últimas voces
o mensajes que nos dejó
el gran Einstein a la humanidad.
Bueno, este manifiesto dio lugar
unos años más tarde a lo que se llaman
las Conferencias Pugwash
para Ciencia y Asuntos Mundiales
en las que yo estoy
activamente involucrada.
En esas conferencias se discuten temas
en la frontera de ciencia y política,
se habla de la responsabilidad social
de los científicos y siempre apelando
a la racionalidad cientifica para
las discusiones y argumentaciones.
Este tipo de trabajo, dio lugar después
a una apertura de canales
de diálogo racional entre los países,
entre ambos lados de la cortina de hierro,
principalmente entre la Unión Soviética
y el resto de los países.
Y después, esto mismo,
el haber abierto canales de diálogo
les mereció el Premio Nobel
de la Paz en 1995.
Tenemos que aprender a pensar de
una nueva manera decían, pero ¿cómo?
Bueno,
debido a mi formación
como científica, como física,
adquirí algo,
una actitud, por la que estoy
muy agradecida
y que es como un entrenamiento mental,
un entrenamiento para pensar,
aprendemos a pensar,
a desarrollar actitudes cognitivas,
que es lo que nos hace
llevar a cabo diariamente
nuestras actividades de científicos
para la investigación.
Parte de esta actividad,
de este pensamiento
incluye el llamado pensamiento
crítico, que es fundamental.
El pensamiento crítico es
el pensamiento del cuestionamiento,
que dice que no debemos quedarnos
con la primera impresión.
El pensamiento crítico como
en este grafiti que encontré,
que me pareció muy divertido
que dice que hay que cuestionar todo
y después al día siguiente, vino alguien
y cuestiona esto recursivamente
y pregunta ¿Por qué?
¡Me encanta esto!
No nos tenemos que quedar
con la primera impresión
porque si nos quedamos
nos volvemos muy vulnerables,
muy prejuiciosos y muy manipulables.
Tenemos que siempre hacer una
vuelta más de tuerca a las cosas.
Gracias al pensamiento crítico
podemos defendernos de
ideas autoritarias, de dogmas
y de fanatismos.
Es muy importante pensar críticamente.
Pero el pensamiento, el pensar,
no solamente incluye
el pensamiento crítico,
tambien incluye otras actividades
dentro de lo que es el pensar,
que me gustaría compartir con ustedes
que hice un juego de palabras,
que es por ejemplo, la evidencia.
La evidencia por supuesto
es parte del pensamiento crítico,
pero queda divertido dentro
del juego de palabras que les presento.
La evidencia, basarnos en la evidencia
para nuestras discusiones,
para nuestras argumentaciones.
También la novedad, lo creativo,
nuestro pensamiento
científico de todos los días
incluye tambien mucha creatividad,
la inspiración, la intuición,
es lo que nos pasa cuando decimos
que se nos prende la lamparita.
Es lo que precede al razonamiento racional
es lo que nos ayuda
a nuevos descubrimientos,
a descubrir nuevos paradigmas.
Es también lo que compartimos
con los artistas,
hay mucho de común.
Tambien la sinceridad, parte del pensar
es ser honestos intelectualmente
Es la posibilidad de aceptar errores,
la de poder mirarnos a los ojos y decir:
"Si, tenés razón, yo estaba equivocada".
Qué poco hacemos eso a diario ¿no?
Aceptar nuestros propios errores
cuando nos convencen.
Para poder pensar necesitamos
la abstracción, la concentración,
la reflexión,
es parte también de lo que pensamos.
El pensar en los valores, en la ética,
en que hacemos y para que lo hacemos
y que consecuencias trae.
Y finalmente, el razonamiento lógico,
el razonamiento analítico, el cuantitativo
el que nos permite
comunicarnos en forma precisa
y el que nos permite evitar
malos entendidos.
Pensar también es como soñar despierto
y yo sueño con un mundo,
en el que todas las personas,
en todos los rincones del mundo,
puedan tener la misma
oportunidad que tuve yo
de aprender, de aprender a pensar.
Que todos los niños y niñas
puedan aprender a pensar
desde muy temprano
aprender de una forma natural.
Aprender como un hábito.
Aprender sin darse cuenta.
Perdón, a pensar sin darse cuenta
y a pensar sin pensar,
como andar en bicicleta.
Que puedan pensar
de una forma natural.
De esa forma,
no tendremos a los chicos
que vengan y que nos digan:
"No, no me gustan las matemáticas,
porque me da fiaca hay que pensar".
Eso no puede ser.
El pensamiento tiene que ser
una actividad cotidiana de siempre,
de toda la vida y en todo momento.
De esa forma, lograremos
un mundo más honesto, más justo,
menos prejuicioso,
lograremos tener... más ético,
una democracia más creíble
En definitiva a creer más,
a confiar más entre nosotros
y a respetarnos más entre todos.
Para ser felices, en eso radica
el cambio cultural que necesitamos.
¡Muchas gracias!